hi
i'm nicole carlson pronounced she heard
together with my co-worker michael we're
going to tell you about our first
collaboration together
where we built a multi-test model to
solve a product classification task at
our
company
let's see so like nicole mentioned uh my
name is michael caronte him his
i'm a senior data scientist at
shoprunner and i enjoy working on our
dji projects
i also enjoy doing things like drawing
stick figures as part of presentations
and my medium profile says i'm a
part-time house cat
but no one has actually commented on
that a typical quote from me
is something like something along the
lines of how can we have more
shenanigans
[Music]
like you said my name is nicole
pronounced i'm a data science manager at
shoprunner i work pretty differently
from michael
i love making lists i'm super into
refactoring code
and every single person on our team has
had me ask could you please advertise
your imports in a pull request
uh so just a little bit of an outline of
what we'll be talking about
so first we'll introduce you to the
problem we're trying to solve which was
product attribute modeling
uh we'll discuss our initial multitask
model
uh then we'll jump to the refactoring
the code section which
is obviously my section since i love
refactoring
uh we'll talk about what happened when
we tried to add a new attribute
as well as discuss our final model and
throughout the presentation
we'll sprinkle in some lessons that we
learned while collaborating with one
another
okay so i'll dive into the next initial
section where i'll give some background
information on the project
that nicole and i were working on for
doing product naturally modeling at
stockbrother
so shoprunner is an e-commerce company
which partners with around 100 different
retailers
and we end up aggregating their product
catalogs
and one of the main data science
concerns we have is being able to sort
of normalize the characteristics
or attributes of these products across
this aggregated catalog
so we started this project we basically
scoped out and said
okay we have this large list of
attributes that we want to be able to
predict
but we'll start with two so we want to
start with color and pattern
and basically for any given product in
our aggregated catalog will say what
their color patterns were
and we wanted to expand and from there
quickly expand to a series of other
attributes like address length sleep
length
but for the purposes of this
presentation so the key one that we're
going to talk about is when you're
trying to add
in season so
for this initial pipeline or section of
the project we
we recognize that probably we can
represent products as both in their
images or their text
but for now we just wanted to focus on
focus on images while we recognize text
is useful and we want to add it later
basically take the image feed it through
a model and be able to predict the
like color and pattern of that given
product
so i'm going to dive into i'm going to
dive into kind of what our initial model
and what that pipeline look like but
first i kind of want to go through
what is multitask learning what it is
and can you eat it
sadly no you can't eat it but i want to
go there's a couple of useful benefits
for doing multitask learning
and the first one i'm going to
illustrate with an example from the
movie karate kid
and in the movie karate kid you have
this uh
the cobra kai are these like group of
schoolyard bullies and essentially
they're
a you can think of it as a single task
that works they learn karate as
violence and they can do that relatively
well but
on the other hand you have the karate
kid and the karate kid expected to be
taught how to fight punch and like kick
things
when he went to go and train mr miyagi
but what mr miyagi does is
teaches him these sort of additional
tasks
and he teaches him how to wax a car
paint a fence
and a walkway and such that when
the karate kid does learn to fight he's
actually able to learn to fight
at a like level equal to or better than
the cobra kai
because he's sort of learned to do these
multiple things simultaneously
and in multicast learning what that
materializes as is
when you train a multitasker network you
should be able to get
equal to a better performance than their
single task counterpart
because of sort of the the model has to
learn the sort of like rich underlying
feature set to solve all these tasks
simultaneously
then the second additional benefit we
have from an industry point of view it
means that we have fewer models to
maintain so sure we could we could solve
a problem by building individual
classifiers for each individual
attribute we have
without it but that basically increases
the burden on our team
so if we can train a single single model
to kind of replace those three
it means that there's less for us to
maintain and monitor infrastructure wise
and less things for us to like
debug over time
so i'm gonna go through to what the
actual like architecture of this initial
model looks like
and what happens is we feed in two
images the first one is a full image and
the second one
is a center crop of that initial image
and essentially the idea here is that
center crop is
helping us inject some detail context
into this model when we for the that
could be useful for like these
actual classifications so what happens
first is we pass each
image through this like core resonant 50
architecture
we get their feature vectors and
concatenate them and then feed them
through the sort of depth network
which is then connected to these final
tasks in this case color and pattern
this is a pipeline that we were able to
build out pretty quickly and pretty
straightforwardly because it's
relatively in line with a lot of quality
catalytic literature
but our problem gets a little bit more
it starts with words it gets a little
more specific
because we it's not just that we want to
predict color pattern we want to predict
all these additional attributes so like
season stress length and sleep length
and what standard multidisciplinary
literature would have us do is maintain
a single
monolithic data set and basically train
use that for training our multi-task
model
but in this case because we're adding it
on iteratively we could add a new task
and then we kind of have to hope and
pray that that task is well represented
in the model of the data set we're
maintaining
if it's not we have to go gather the
data set and then kind of mark both
mark both data sets and merge them
together which is kind of a very
time consuming potentially expensive
task over time
so i was kind of hoping to see is there
something else we could do
and what i came across was i was
re-watching a
lecture from anja ning which is
discussing multitask learning
and he mentions kind of offhandedly that
multitask learning also works if some of
the images are only partially labeled
or images or samples and the idea here
was that okay maybe we can get to
something else where we don't have to
mark every sample
like every image every sample everything
else but maybe we can get to a point
where
we have specific data sets which are
marked for specific tasks and use those
to train those specific tasks
but this is a thing that i knew could
probably be done because andrew ning
mentioned it but
i didn't know how to get there so
there's a lot of research uh
reading papers blogs tutorials really
anything i could find about multitask
learning implementing it code and then
just failing for a long period of time
and just this iterating this very
vicious feedback cycle
and personally for to like figure out
this problem it wasn't until like i was
able to like successfully distance
myself from the problem that i was able
to figure out like kind of what i was
doing wrong
and i realized this while i was doing
inspired sessions with wing chun kung fu
where i realized that i wasn't really
setting up the pipelines in
such a way that the model was getting
explicit and clear feedback for like
good classifications and mistakes it was
making at any given point in time so
that
then i thought okay maybe if i can
simplify or like make this feedback more
explicit it can actually learn
and of course this happened while in a
sparring session so i kind of lost my
focus got punched repeatedly in the
chest but
hashtag worth it because it helped me
figure out
this uh concept of multi-data set
multitask learning
and essentially what have what i like
ended up thinking about was
okay say we have these data sets which
represent individual tasks
so we're saying we have two two for now
but really be any number
and what we do is we take these batches
our data sets prepare their batches and
kind of shuffle them together into this
random grab bag
and then what we start doing is you
start drawing out one by one
and feeding it through our model so
let's say in this case say we draw the
color batch we feed it through the model
the model is actually going to predict
both color and pattern but what we're
only we're going to do is only score it
based on color
because that's what we have the labels
for in this case and then we'll use that
for back propagation
on a future iteration say we pick out a
pattern batch we feed that through it's
an output prediction for both color and
pattern
but we only score the results from
pattern and use that for that
complication
and then an epic in this training cycle
ends when the last batch is sort of
drawn out of this graphic
and the end result here is that you have
a model that has never seen a sample
that has
both color and pattern marked but it can
make good predictions for both of those
tasks
so at the end of this initial r v
process training on a relatively small
data set and
with this image only model have cut we
had color at about like 84 percent
and pattern 82 which is fine with the
starting point and we realized we'd get
additional benefits when we added a text
so now it's over to nicole to sort of
add in that section of the model
architecture
uh yeah so this is when i joined the
project
michael was working on another piece of
work at shop runner
and i was interested in joining the
project because i hadn't had any deep
learning experience before
and i thought i should work with the
master michael to figure out what was
going on
so i was really excited excited to uh
look at the code and figure out what's
going on and my initial goal for this
type of
this part of the project was to start
using text so we wanted to use both the
images
and the text of a product like the name
and product description
to predict those same tasks that michael
described before
color and pattern so the specific model
we ended up putting in for the text was
a burp model
because michael had experience with bert
models so he had some existing code he
could work off of
so we still took in that same full image
and cropped image and
sent it through a resnet at the same
time we're sending through the product
text through a burp model
in both of these cases we get some
output vector
then we send them through the dense
layers and then out again to the
color and pattern task kit so i knew
what i was supposed to be doing
now i just had to get it implemented in
code
so my first step was to read through all
the work that michael had done
as we mentioned previously michael works
quite differently than i do
so he had all of his code in cheaper
notebooks
um he had done a variety of rounds of
training
so there was a lot of duplicate
information in the dope books
along with his notes about what had
happened with each learning rate with
freezing various parts etc so it was a
lot for me
to dig through and
as i was reading through it
i noticed uh that there were a number of
things that were
um repeated throughout the code so
um there was this multi-attribute model
this trained model function was copied a
number of times
i also saw that there were a number of
cases where michael had hard-coded in
the tasks themselves so there were
references to color
and to pattern within the uh
within the model uh the software
engineer in me looked at this and said
i bet there's a way we can do this
without hard coding in the tasks
and since we know we want to add
additional tasks this will make it more
flexible for us to work with this in the
future
so as i was reading through these
notebooks as i was seeing this stuff
i decided to pull out the common code
into
python scripts i initially did this for
myself because i thought it would help
me understand what was going on with the
training
if i was able to separate out the parts
that were repeated
versus the parts that were different so
i went ahead
and refactored all the code so i created
a multi-data set loader
this was to do the shuffling that
michael just mentioned of the different
tasks
i created a resnet for multi-task
classification so
this was uh basically the model that
michael described earlier
where you have the resonant and the
different tasks head and i created it so
that it could work for an arbitrary
number of tasks
and then finally i also created a
multi-task learner
to do the training and validation and
this class took care of the
back propagation of the different losses
for the different tasks
so i was kind of all set up and ready
to um to start adding in
the text and since i already had the
resonant for multi-class
multi-task classification it was
relatively straightforward for me to
figure out how to do
the same thing for a burp model so i
created a
text model for multitask classification
as well as
the ensemble model that would combine
the burt and resnet outputs
to the task heads so i was feeling
pretty good about this
i had some separated out code i felt
like i
kind of understood what was going on
better since i actually had
worked through some of the code myself
and had these python scripts
so i decided to train a single tasks
for color and pattern using my ensemble
image and text models as you recall i
said that
the models would work for an arbitrary
number of tasks one is a number
so i went ahead and did that and for
color
using image and text only you got 95
accuracy
and for pattern we got about 86 accuracy
i also thought it was really important
for us to have a baseline because this
would help us tell if our multi-task
model
was actually working as well as we
thought it could
multitask models should do ideally about
as well as
training each task individually and
sometimes they can even do a little bit
better
if the tasks work well together
so uh having the single task models
i went ahead and trained the multi-task
model and
our multi-task model got about 93 for
color and 84
per pattern you'll notice that this is a
little bit higher than the image only
results that michael got
previously so we felt good that the text
was actually adding something to this
project and was worthwhile
and for our use case the two percent
drop in accuracy
uh was not super important because we
could always set a threshold
so i was feeling great i had refactored
this entire code base
and i had
met the goal that i had set out to which
was to build an image and text model
great wrong
uh i have been doing this all by myself
just heads down
and i did not tell michael anything
about what was going on
as you can see from this poll request i
changed 33 files
in his library and i was only supposed
to be adding in text
so i had completely changed to this
library
and i didn't tell michael at all was
going on
which was a really shitty thing to do
so that brought us to our first lesson
uh which is that it's super important to
communicate with somebody especially if
you're going to change their entire
library
nobody likes coming back to a poll
request with 33 files
uh had i gone to michael earlier and
explained what i was trying to do
uh he wouldn't have felt as blind-sided
when i came back with all these changes
and since he knew the code base a lot
better i'm sure he could have
given me a lot of tips along the way as
i was refactoring the code
another lesson that we learned is how
important it is to make your
collaborators feel valued so
during this time that um we had this
conflict we actually each went to our
boss and said
uh i don't think i'm contributing enough
so i was like oh michael did all the
deep learning stuff all they did was
software engineering it doesn't matter
at all
michael went to our boss and said nicole
did all this refactoring it's totally
awesome like all i did was put in some
neural networks
so we were both sitting there feeling
conflicted even though we
both respected each other a lot and
we're uh deeply admirable of what the
other person is doing
so if you get to a point like that tell
the other person what's going on
uh there's no downside and everyone will
feel better
so once we resolve some of our conflict
we had this library
that was in a good place where we could
add
new tasks onto our
our model so we decided it was time
to add a new attribute and the initial
attribute we wanted to add was season
um so we're going to take basically our
same model architecture that already had
color and pattern and add season on
and just like i had done previously the
first step was for me to train a single
task
season image and text model just so we
get a baseline
of what we were working with so uh
i i trained that model and our season
accuracy was about 86 percent
so i was feeling great i know exactly
how to train a multi-task model no
problem
wrong as soon as we trained a multi-task
model
no matter what i did with the learning
rates the optimizers whatever
the multi-task accuracy stayed really
low
so color was at about 89 pattern was at
82
season was all the way down at 74
percent so something very bizarre was
happening
uh and i also noticed that it was only
happening with the resnet
uh when i looked at just the text models
by themselves the multi-task model could
do well
but the image only model or the ensemble
model was just failing completely
so uh i had no idea what to do but then
i thought
wait i know someone who's very good at
deep learning who might be able to
shed some light on what's happening
see yeah so when nicole contacted me
about this problem i was like
wow what is even happening because in
multicast learning literature
basically what like one of those main
benefits that they like mentioned
frequently is that as long as you have
this related domain of tasks you should
basically be getting equal to a better
performance than their single test
counterparts
so that's kind of for a while it's quite
i was really at a loss
and what it felt like was one of those
like fairy tale or fantasy type tropes
where you can find the name of the
creature in order to like beat or banish
it
and so for me it just became this like
search through literature or
basically pouring through everything i
read about multitask learning all the
research papers blog tutorials
really anything i could find looking for
like references to the
something that has these symptoms and
big breakthrough king i was rereading
this one particular post out of a
research group from stanford
but they mentioned kind of offhandedly
that they have they took certain steps
to mitigate something that they called
uh destructive interference and while
they didn't say
like what it was or like what exactly
the problems the cause were
i was able to do further research from
there and kind of stick around like oh
the symptoms of destructive interference
and multitask learning are kind of match
what we're seeing here
so destructive interference is this idea
of physics where it's like
opposite signals will cancel each other
out but in multi-test learning what
they kind of use it to refer to is this
idea where you have these multiple tasks
which aren't really aligned with one
another
or aren't that related to one another as
far as the neural network is concerned
so you might have this one task season
and it's going to say okay you should go
this direction in order to optimize
my problem space and then the network
will like okay
sure let's go in that direction and then
the other the other tasks say
pattern color in this case we'll say
okay you should go this opposite
direction or optimize to us
so what happens is you get this network
that's kind of pulled back and forth in
this conflicting directions
such that like it might look like it's
converging on the solution
but what happens is it doesn't really
learn to do any of the tasks
particularly well
and you see this sort of drop off and
performance on everything
so now that we had this like identified
this
problem destructive interference knew
the symptoms and sort of knew what
caused it
nicole and i were at the spot where we
could start uh
training up our i guess final models and
solutions to this problem
yeah so uh once michael mentioned this
um i was super excited that we had a
name for what was going on
and we immediately nerd sniped our
entire data science team
and sat in front of a whiteboard for an
entire afternoon during
out whatever ideas we possibly had to
try and solve this problem
so uh one initial thought we had was
let's just give up on multitask learning
and have
one single task one single model per
task
uh we obviously didn't really want to do
this because we didn't want to maintain
these many models we didn't want to have
all these different services to maintain
so uh we pretty quickly scrapped that
idea
another idea we discussed was having one
model per related task group
so we had seen that color and pattern
seemed to train well together and season
uh didn't so maybe we separate things
out that way
this is still not a very satisfactory
solution for us because
uh we knew anytime we added a new task
we'd have to train
every single model uh all the way
through with the new test to figure out
if it
destructively interfered with an
existing task or paired well
and that just seemed like way too much
work we also would have had
uh multiple models to maintain which we
again did not want to do
another pie in the sky idea we had was
to
just have one resonant per task so i had
mentioned that the interference only
seemed to be happening with the resident
the burp model seemed to be able to
handle all the different complexities of
the tasks
so one thought was well just leave the
burnt model for all the tasks and have
separate residents
we were also not very excited about this
because we knew
that some of the tasks should train well
together
and some of them should be working on
very similar tasks
so for example dress length and sleeve
length uh we're just we need a model
that can find a horizontal line in the
picture
so it seems really wasteful to have
separate resonance to find a horizontal
line
so the final solution we came up with
was to have one resnet per related task
group
so we would have a color and pattern
resonant which would combine with the
output from burp model
and a season resonant which would
combine but they output from the same
bert model
uh sent off to you the various task
heads
so uh we were very excited about this
because we knew now we could get tasks
that trained well together to
to get the benefits of training together
while still allowing the
tasks that destructively interfered with
one another to be separate from one
another
in the resident so uh i
went through our code base and modified
our resonant architecture and our
ensemble architecture to be able to
handle this new
complication of having an arbitrary of
resonance with an arbitrary number of
tests
but once i got that all set up i was
able to retrain the
multitask model and our accuracies got
way better
so our color accuracy went up to about
94 pattern
to 85 percent and season was at 84
so uh we were super excited about this
and in fact you can see
that color and pattern are actually
slightly better uh than when it was just
the color and pattern
uh ensemble by itself so we're feeling
really good
uh we had this new multitask library all
set up
we knew we would be able to easily add
existing new tasks to existing models
and for me this last uh piece of work
where we discovered this destructive
interference was a a really good
reminder of how important it is to
balance different work styles when you
work with somebody who is very different
from how you work
in this case um having michael do a
bunch of research and
test a bunch of things in jupiter
notebooks worked out really well when
paired with my
um my ability to kind of abstract things
into classes and code and to really
think through
the software engineering side of things
so
uh i'd say if you're collaborating with
somebody else who works very differently
from you make sure you play to your
strengths while at the same time still
learning from one another
[Music]
yeah so at this point we felt pretty
good about everything because we have
this library
super cool at least from our point of
view and it supports things like
you can easily add in new tasks you can
have model classes
and we have this like fun multi-data set
training functionality
we also found that our like the code
base is nice and usable because we have
lots of our teammates who actually
use it for both personal and other
internal sharpener projects
and found to be like pretty
straightforward to use and were able to
get things up and running
and in addition to these things nicole
and i are both pretty passionate about
open sourcing and really this like idea
of giving back to our community as a
whole
so with all these things sort of like
lining up together our new steps were
pretty clear
so what we did was we uh open sourced
our library called octopod
and it is this uh pytorch-based
multi-task learning framework that we
really build up for our
like internal sharpeners like uh
actually modern use cases but we found
the extremely useful for a variety of
things
so we just wanted to like put it out
there in the community
and it supports things like the
multi-data set training we mentioned
multiple inputs images text of course
the multiple tasks
it's a core piece of the functionality
and then we have the ability to
sort of tie together models very freely
so like multiple resonance
to make ensembles with text models and
kind of really any way you want to mix
and match those
and then we also have things like
multiple loss functions with the idea
that different tasks might require
like very personalized loss functions
for those tasks
and so at the bottom here we have the
github and ipi links for our october
vpro
then one other lesson that we have is
that really it's like a super fun
rewarding experience to work with
like for nicole and i to work with
someone who has opposite strengths
like ourselves and really making this
library together is something
that once we figured out how to
collaborate well together it's something
we were able to make something that
really neither of us could have made on
our own
and it kind of reinforced that lesson
that
how it's fun and rewarding to work with
the awards is very different from you
because that's
that is really how you end up growing as
a like
software engineer data scientist as a
person getting exposed to those new ways
of thinking
so to wrap it up uh we'd like to give a
quick shout out and thanks to the
shopper data science team for allowing
us to repeatedly nerd snipe them
and for all their support and also for
the guidance of our former manager ali
vandeveld
then we have the contact information for
nicole myself so my medium medium handle
and then nicole's twitter handle
and then once again we have the links
for the octopod github and ipi links